St. LOUIS WILL SEE
TIPPED BY START NOW TO
CHASE THE GAME ANDND CLEARED
AND THOMPSON, BREAKING THROUGH T
NOW WAITING TO STOP THINGS UP
HERE.
VICTOR OLOFSSON WITH A SHOT NOW
THE SECOND AND SEE IF
ARM COULD NOT GET IT OUT.
CHECK THERE, LEHKONEN.
THE PUCK NOW TO BY PITLICK.
>>
>> Greg: THERE WER IT.
NOW PLAYING ITreg: THEY ALMOST E
THIS, GOOD PUCK RECOVERY, RIGHT
HERE AND HOFFM AND NOW NET.
THAT IS LOVED BY IS ROLLED BACKT
LEAVES A WIDE OPEN SKINNER HERE
AND EVERYONE CHASING DAHLIN HERE
AN
>> John: KULAK, IN FRONT.
AND PITLICK HERE, COULD NOT FOR
HIM.
TTEMPT.
IT IS HANDED OFF NOW FOR PETRY,
GOALTENDER THEY JUST CHUCK IT IN
PERIOD NUMBER WITH A OKPOSO AFTN
NOW, CATCHING UP TO
>> John: AND ANOTHER GOOD ANSWER
HERE AND ANDERSON, A VERY
MONTEMBEAULT HERE WITH THE SAVE.
IS CLAGUE.
TO GALLAGHER.
HE WILL DEFLECT IS FITZGERALD, F
THE BO TERRIFIC
LISTEN.
>> John: YES,
CREATING A COUNTERATTACK AND
THAT WAS GOING TO BE A PENALTY
THE SUPERINTENDENT CHALMERS RIGK
YOU VERY MUCH
HIS PLAN HERE.
>> John: THE TOP LINE IS BACK
ASS